all right joining me now Florida
Congressman Matt Gates who has voted 11
times for candidates other than McCarthy
Congressman great to see you tonight I
love seeing you by the way with
congresswoman Jaya Paul what were you
talking about there I love seeing that
video any scoop you can give us that was
fun I'm like what what are they talking
about
my conversations with Democrats have
largely been about making sure that they
don't leave the floor for dinner or
fundraisers or whatnot we need them to
stay there so that the denominator in
the equation on the election of a
speaker allows us to have leverage to
push for many of the things we've been
discussing on the budget on term limits
on the really the order of the House of
Representatives so committee assignments
and chairmanships aren't bought and sold
based on who's able to redistribute the
most lobbyist money while the American
people are often left behind in a
corrupt broken system in Congress yeah I
think that your point about
um you know rushing off to events with
Consultants or fundraisers is important
um I saw there was a fundraising email
sent out by Andy Biggs who's one of the
other individuals of course opposing
McCarthy and he sent a fundraiser out as
the action was happening on the floor
saying we block Kevin McCarthy for
becoming speaker of the house but now we
conservatives must lead the fight to get
the leadership we deserve Congressman
Gates is that the right you know we love
Congressman Biggs but is that the right
approach uh given your message about
don't run out to the fundraisers
well I don't want to make sure people
stayed on the floor I've sent out
similar emails and the reason is because
Pro McCarthy groups have actually been
running Robo calls in our districts
trying to pressure us and leverage us so
yes when you have Kevin McCarthy
utilizing his extensive political
resources to battle against house
conservatives we want the great Patriots
all throughout this land to go to
mattgates.com chip in so that I can
fight back and get a message out about
the great things that we are working to
achieve and it is not the end of the
world that we take a few extra days or
maybe even a couple weeks to sort this
out I mean Laura you know this there are
some days in Congress where the only
thing we vote on is the changing of the
name of one post office now we're
deciding who's second in line to the
presidency and the construct of these
rules concessions functionally term the
speakership into a ceremonial position
matter of fact if my colleagues get what
they want from McCarthy the chairman of
the freedom caucus will actually be more
important than the Speaker of the House
in determining the legislative nation
that reaches the floor how amendments
are processed and how it's spending
occurs going forward yeah I I get why
you know you know on on the
establishment issues I'm totally with
you okay but I'm always also about the
art of the possible what's possible here
so you did get a number of concessions
that I'm not sure if I were on the other
side I would have given you but a number
of concessions from McCarthy an attempt
to get you know to 218. so he lowered
the threshold of the votes required to
begin uh the process of removing himself
a speaker just one person one member of
the conference can do it now and to keep
uh he also agreed to keep his own pack
out of GOP primaries and also to add
more freedom caucus members to the house
rules committee and I understand he also
signed on to a separate approval process
for earmarks and allowed floor votes on
term limits for members in specific
border policy legislation
what else do you require that he do or
agree to before Matt Gates will say okay
I'm on board
I wouldn't be betting on my vote for
Kevin McCarthy under almost any
circumstance but it's important to note
that all of those things
hold on hold on hold on wait and that's
personal then you know you just made
this very principled point no no you
can't have it both ways you can't say I
am I'm a man of principle and I believe
in X Y and Z but if he gives me X Y and
Z I'm not going to vote for him what
well here's how do you know that makes
sense here's how it makes sense Laura
Kevin McCarthy is the Masthead of the
lobby Corps and I resent the extent to
which Kevin McCarthy utilizes the
lobbyists and the special interests to
be able to dictate how political
decisions are made how policy decisions
are made and how leadership decisions
are made Kevin McCarthy has been in the
leadership for 14 years and he has sold
shares of himself to special interests
to political action committees and so
that's why I don't think he is an
appropriate Choice he also has no
ideology
what's that why is Trump why I mean you
you are very close I mean look I love
president yes why is Trump Forum I mean
how many how many posts on Truth social
can we see from president Trump telling
y'all okay this is this has been fun but
let's let's wrap it up here
well I see President Trump I I he I love
president Trump I defended him a great
deal in Congress but uh HR wasn't always
his strong suit you know president Trump
got us folks like Jeff sessions and Bill
Barr and Jim Mattis and Mark esper
people who didn't always Advance America
First policy so I well I think
I do I think president Trump is wrong to
the extent that he supports Kevin
McCarthy I'm going to support president
Trump if he or when he runs uh for
reelection in 2024 but I'm not going to
back him on this play so look if we are
able to get there are you going to be
okay Congressman will you be okay then
if there's ultimately a deal struck with
moderate Democrats that give Democrats
kind of co-control of the Committees
you're fine with that no absolutely not
that that will not happen there are two
people scenarios here no that listen I'm
on the floor Laura these 212 Democrats
are going to vote for Hakeem Jeffries
every single time he is a historic
candidate for them they are not going to
cleave off under any circumstance I
assure you that if Democrats join up to
elect a moderate Republican I will
resign from the House of Representatives
that is how certain I am I can assure
your viewers that won't happen are you
sorry Steve scalise okay for you or no
Steve's there are two no well that
depends on if he if he would accept
these rules that we've spent a lot of
time on so we'd have to have that
discussion with Steve scalise so far
Steve scalise hasn't indicated that he
would run I would far prefer Jim Jordan
and if Kevin McCarthy pulls out of the
race
I do expect Jim Jordan to mount a
campaign oh well he hasn't running yet
if ju if look if Kevin McCarthy got out
of this race and Jim Jordan would get
into it that's my belief and I believe
Jim Jordan would win I think he would
invigorate our movement I think he's
broadly trusted in every corner of the
Republican party and with a lot of our
donors and supporters and activists
that's the type of option if Kevin
McCarthy bows out if Kevin McCarthy
doesn't bow out then he will have to
live the entirety of his speakership in
a straight jacket constructed by these
rules that we're working on now
so in your and you you prefer a speaker
with a straight jacket than one who you
believe is just a spin-a-rama right well
I prefer a straight shot if it's Kevin
McCarthy if it was a Jim Jordan we
certainly wouldn't need that because we
trust Jim Jordan we have zero trust in
Kevin McCarthy and there's just a large
body of work to evaluate his continuous
voting for big spending bills his
support of amnesty in the past his
refusal to join us in trying to break up
big tests Republican this is someone
who's who's like Compass is like a wet
finger in the Wind
all right Congressman Gates we're going
to be watching this very closely
tomorrow we can't can't wait to see what
happens next thank you very much for
joining us we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else